>>> BREAKING NEWS.
DAMAR HAMLIN'S UNCLE TELLING CNN
THAT HE HAD TO BE RESUSCITATED
TWICE.
AND THIS IS THE FIRST TIME THAT
WE ARE HEARING FROM A MEMBER OF
HIS FAMILY ABOUT HIS CONDITION.
AND IT COMES ALONG WITH WHAT
WE'RE HEARING FROM A SOURCE WITH
THE BILLS WHO SAYS THAT THE TEAM
IS IN WAIT AND SEE "MODE.
THAT SAME SOURCE ALSO ADDS THAT
THE BILLS' PLAYERS AND STAFF ARE
STILL PROCESSING WHAT THEY SAW
HAPPEN ON THE FIELD, COLLAPSING
GOING INTO CARDIAC ARREST BEFORE
HAVING HIS HEARTBEAT RESTORED.
AND AT THIS HOUR HAMLIN IS IN
CRITICAL CONDITION IN THE
INTENSIVE UNIT.
ADRIENNE BROADDUS HAS HAD THE
CHANCE TO SPEAK TO HIS FAMILY,
HIS UNCLE, AND LEARNING THIS
CRUCIAL DEVELOPMENT ABOUT HIM
HAVING TO BE RESUSCITATED TWICE.
WHAT DID HE TELL YOU?
>> HE SAID THE FAMILY IS
HEARTBROKEN.
I SPOKE WITH HIM RIGHT HERE AT
THE CORNER OF THE HOSPITAL.
I APPROACHED HIM IN FULL
TRANSPARENCY WHEN I WALKED BY, I
HEARD HIM SPEAKING ON THE PHONE
WITH SOMEONE, AND HE WAS
DESCRIBING HOW HIS HEART
DROPPED.
AND INITIALLY I THOUGHT THIS
PERSON MIGHT'VE BEEN A PLAYER.
I NOTICED HE HAD ON A VISITOR
TAG, AND THEN I ASKED HIM IF HE
WAS A PLAYER, AND HE SAID NO, MY
NEPHEW IS INSIDE.
HERE'S MORE OF THAT
CONVERSATION.
>> UM, HE'S STILL SEDATED RIGHT
NOW.
THEY JUST WANT HIM TO HAVE A
BETTER CHANCE OF RECOVERING
BETTER.
SO THEY FELT IF HE'S SEDATED,
HIS BODY CAN HEAL A LOT FASTER
THAN IF HE WAS WOKE AND POSSIBLY
CAUSE OTHER COMPLICATIONS.
SO THEY GOT HIM SEDATED RIGHT
NOW.
IT'S JUST HEARTBREAKING SEEING
HIM LIKE THAT.
WE WERE IN PITTSBURGH WATCHING
IT ON TV, AND HIS LITTLE BROTHER
WAS THERE WITH US.
AND WHEN HE SEEN HIS BROTHER
DROP LIKE THAT, AND WHEN I TELL
YOU I NEVER SEEN HIM SCREAM LIKE
THAT, WE WERE TRYING TO CALM HIM
DOWN, LIKE, IT'S OKAY, HE'LL BE
BACK IN THE GAME.
NEXT THING YOU KNOW, TEN MINUTES
LATER THEY'RE DOING CHEST
COMPRESSIONS.
HALF HOUR LATER, THEY'RE STILL
NOT PLAYING.
AND WHEN I SAY, LIKE, NOW WE
WERE ALL IN THE ROOM CRYING, WE
WERE ALL IN TEARS.
AND I'M NOT A CRIER, BUT I NEVER
CRIED SO HARD IN MY LIFE JUST TO
KNOW MY NEPHEW BASICALLY DIED ON
THE FIELD AND THEY BROUGHT HIM
BACK TO LIFE.
THAT'S JUST HEARTBREAKING.
AND TO SEE ALL THOSE GROWN MEN
CRYING AND ALL THE EMOTION, IT
REALLY WAS A GUT PUNCH, MAN.
I WOULD HAVE BEEN CRYING NO
MATTER WHO IT WAS.
BUT FOR IT TO BE MY NEPHEW, IT
HAD THAT MUCH MORE IMPACT ON ME.
AND I'M JUST GLAD HE'S STILL
ALIVE AND ABLE TO FIGHT AND
TRYING TO GET BETTER AND
RECOVER.
>> YOU TOLD ME OFF CAMERA YOUR
NEPHEW DIED TWICE.
CAN YOU EXPLAIN?
>> HIS HEART WENT OUT.
THEY HAD TO RESUSCITATE HIM
TWICE.
THEY RESUSCITATED HIM ON THE
FIELD, AND THEN THEY
RESUSCITATED HIM AGAIN WHEN HE
GOT TO THE HOSPITAL.
I JUST WANT TO SHOW MY GRATITUDE
FOR THE MEDICAL STAFF THAT WERE
ON HAND.
BECAUSE IF NOT FOR THEM, MY
NEPHEW PROBABLY WOULDN'T EVEN BE
HERE.
>> AN ABUNDANCE OF GRATITUDE FOR
THE MEDICAL STAFF HERE.
HE ALSO DESCRIBED WHAT HE HAD
SEEN INSIDE OF THE HOSPITAL.
HE SAID HIS NEPHEW IS FLIPPED
OVER ON HIS STOMACH.
AND THAT IS TO HELP WITH THE
BLOOD ON HIS LUNGS.
HE ALSO SAYS THE NEXT STEP IS
FOR DOCTORS TO GET HIS NEPHEW TO
BREATHE ON HIS OWN.
AND HE SAYS HE WAS ONLY OUTSIDE
BECAUSE HE NEEDED TO GET SOME
FRESH AIR.
HE TOLD ME HE HAS BEEN IN THIS
HOSPITAL ALL DAY, OVERNIGHT WITH
HIS FAMILY, INCLUDING DAMAR'S
MOTHER WHO RODE IN THE AMBULANCE
WITH HER 24-YEAR-OLD SON
YESTERDAY.
BACK TO YOU.
>> ADRIENNE, THANK YOU VERY
MUCH, REPORTING THERE LIVE FROM
CINCINNATI.
REALLY CRUCIAL DETAILS HERE AS
WE ALL TRY TO UNDERSTAND WHAT
HAPPENED AND WHAT WILL HAPPEN.
OUR CHIEF MEDICAL CORRESPONDENT
IS ALONG WITH ME ALONG WITH
DR. JONATHAN REINER WHO IS THE
DIRECTOR OF THE CARDIAC CALF
LAB.
DOCTOR, OF COURSE, SOMETHING
THAT YOU KNOW FROM PERSONAL
EXPERIENCE.
SANJAY, FIRST, LET ME ASK YOU
ABOUT WHAT ADRIENNE IS JUST
REPORTING FROM DAMAR HAMLIN'S
UNCLE, THAT HE WAS RESUSCITATED
TWICE, ONCE ON THE FIELD AND
ONCE WHEN HE GOT TO THE
HOSPITAL, THAT HE OBVIOUSLY IS
STILL NOT BREATHING ON HIS OWN,
AND THAT HE'S FLIPPED ON HIS
STOMACH BECAUSE OF POSSIBILITY
OF BLOOD CLOTTING IN HIS LUNGS.
WHAT, OF ALL OF THAT, STANDS OUT
TO YOU, AND WHY?
>> WELL, IT SOUNDS LIKE,
OBVIOUSLY THIS IS A VERY
SIGNIFICANT CARDIAC EVENT HERE.
WE STILL DON'T KNOW EXACTLY WHAT
CAUSED THIS CARDIAC EVENT.
BUT WHAT WE HEARD FROM THE
BILLS' STATEMENT ORIGINALLY WAS
THAT THEY WERE ABLE TO RESTART
OR OBTAIN A NORMAL RHYTHM OF HIS
HEART WHEN HE WAS ON THE FIELD.
BUT THEN IT SOUNDS LIKE HE
DETERIORATED AGAIN AND NEEDED TO
BE RESUSCITATED AGAIN WHEN HE
WAS AT THE HOSPITAL.
SOMETIMES WHEN THE HEART IS NOT
FUNCTIONING WELL, YOU START TO
HAVE FLUID THAT STARTS TO BUILD
UP, AND THE FLUID CAN BUILD UP
IN THE LUNGS, IT CAN BUILD UP IN
OTHER PARTS OF THE BODY.
THAT MAY BE WHAT ADRIENNE AND, I
GUESS, HIS UNCLE WAS DESCRIBING
THERE.
AND YOU DO IMPLEMENT VARIOUS
TECHNIQUES TO MAKE IT EASIER TO
ACTUALLY PROVIDE OXYGEN AND
ELIMINATE CARBON DIOXIDE FROM
THE BODY.
AND SOMETIMES FLIPPING THE
PATIENT OVER ONTO THEIR STOMACH
CAN HELP FACILITATE THAT.
IT'S SPECULATIVE.
I JUST WANT TO BE CLEAR.
WE'RE GOING ON VERY LITTLE
INFORMATION HERE, AND THESE
DESCRIPTIONS SO I WANT TO BE
VERY CAREFUL, ERIN IN, TRYING
TO, A, WE'RE NOT EVEN CERTAIN OF
THE DIAGNOSIS AT THIS POINT,
WHAT EXACTLY CAUSED ALL THIS,
AND, B, WHAT EXACTLY IS
HAPPENING.
BUT WE DO KNOW FOR SURE FROM
THAT ORIGINAL STATEMENT IS THAT
HE DID HAVE A CARDIAC ARREST.
THIS WAS A CARDIAC HEART-RELATED
EVENT OF SOME SORT.
BUT WHAT EXACTLY IT WAS AND HOW
IT NOW IS BEING TREATED, I THINK
WE'RE STARTING TO GET MORE
DETAILS OF.
>> DR. REINER, DO IIN OF THESE
DETAILS, WHETHER IT BE THE NEED
FOR A SECOND RESUSCITATION OR
ANYTHING ELSE STAND OUT TO YOU
AS A CARDIAC SURGEON?
>> YEAH.
FIRST OF ALL, OUR NOTICE THAT HE
NEEDED TO BE RESUSCITATED A
SECOND TIME WHEN HE GOT TO THE
HOSPITAL SUGGESTS THAT
MR. HAMLIN'S HEART WAS WHAT WE
WOULD CALL ELECTRICALLY VERY
IRRITABLE.
NOT ONLY HAD HE HAD THE FIRST
CARDIAC ARREST ON THE FIELD, BUT
HE THEN ESSENTIALLY RELAPSED AND
HAD A SECOND CARDIAC ARREST,
SUGGESTING, AGAIN, THAT HE WAS
REALLY NOT ELECTRICALLY STABLE.
THE SECOND PIECE OF INFORMATION,
WHICH WE HAD CERTAINLY NOT HEARD
BEFORE, IS THAT MR. HAMLIN IS IN
THE PRONE POSITION.
THAT IS USED ONLY WHEN IT IS
VERY DIFFICULT TO OXYGENATE OR
MOVE GASES IN AND OUT THROUGH
THE LUNGS, POTENTIALLY BECAUSE
HE WAS IN SOMETHING CALLED
PULMONARY EDEMA.
AND THIS HAPPENS WHEN THE HEART
IS SIMPLY NOT FUNCTIONING.
AND, AS YOU SAID, AND AS SANJAY
SAID WHEN, FLUID BACKS UP IN THE
LUNGS.
BUT TAKING IT AS A WHOLE, WHAT
THIS SUGGESTS IS THAT HE'S JUST
INCREDIBLY CRITICALLY ILL AT
THIS TIME.
AND HE'S FORTUNATE TO BE IN AN
INSTITUTION THAT HAS THE
CAPACITY TO PROVIDE THIS LEVEL
OF CARE.
>> SANJAY, WHAT ARE THE POSSIBLE
IMPLICATIONS OF A SITUATION LIKE
THIS WHEN YOU THINK ABOUT, AS HE
GETS BETTER, AND WE ALL OF
COURSE HOPE THAT HE GETS BETTER.
HE IS IN INTENSIVE CARE.
WE DON'T KNOW WHAT CONDITION HE
IS IN.
CAN YOU FULLY RECOVER FROM THIS?
I KNOW IT'S HARD BECAUSE WE
DON'T KNOW EXACTLY WHAT THE THIS
IS.
BUT FROM THE POSITION HE'S IN
AND THE TIME THAT'S PASSED, CAN
SOMEONE LIKE THAT LIKELY HAVE A
FULL RECOVERY?
>> WELL, HE'S A YOUNG PERSON.
THAT CERTAINLY IS GOING TO WORK
IN HIS FAVOR.
I THINK WHAT WE'RE MISSING IS A
COUPLE OF REALLY CRITICAL PIECES
OF INFORMATION.
WE STILL DON'T KNOW EXACTLY WHAT
CAUSED THIS.
WAS THERE AN UNDERLY